it was an impeccably choreographed event
designed to showcase China's
transformation from an inward-looking
farming based society to the economic
giant it is today the country's
President Xi Jingping credited 40 years
of what he termed socialism with Chinese
characteristics for lifting people out
of poverty and putting China on the
international stage but that stage now
more than ever is fraught with tension
in a thinly veiled reference to his
country's months-long trade dispute with
the United States ji had this to say
there's no textbook of rules to follow
for the reforms and opening of China a
country with 5,000 years of history and
civilization and with a population of
more than 1.3 billion people no one is
in a position to dictate to the Chinese
people what should or shouldn't be done
no one not even seemingly the leader of
the most powerful economy in the world
this footage shows Xi Jinping having
dinner with US President Donald Trump at
the g20 summit in Argentina earlier this
month the result was an agreement to a
90 day truce in their trade conflict but
the arrests since then of a top
executive at Chinese tech equipment
giant Huawei has left that truce on
shaky ground than ever the tone coming
from Beijing today was defiant China
won't be pushed around
I wanna talk about that I'm joined now
by Gordon Chang he is a columnist and
author who has written it frequently on
China he joins me tonight from Florida
mr. Cheng it's good to have you on the
show so we've got China doing what the
US has been doing putting on a show of
strength we've got a lot of show here
which side though would you say has the
sharpest teeth well that's clearly the
United States
remember the u.s. is the trade deficit
country and during trade wars if you
call them that deficit countries
basically don't worry about the friction
it's the surplus countries that worry
about it
also China has an overwhelming
dependence on the US last year China's
merchandise trade surplus against
America was eighty eight point nine
percent of their overall merchandise
trade surplus that is overwhelming
dependence on the US market and Chinese
companies like ZTE and Huawei depend on
US technology you put all that together
I think that the only factor of the US
may not have and it's the most important
factor but the only factor that the US
may not have is political will we've got
to see who has more of that you tweeted
earlier today correct me if I'm wrong
here I'm you tweeted I'm now optimistic
that there will be no trade deal and we
do not need another deal with China
which it will violate we need the
Chinese to stop trade violations and
stop stealing our intellectual property
that yes that's true intellectual
property theft is rampant do you see any
signs though that China is going to stop
that or that the United States has the
the capability of stopping it well you
know I don't think China's going to stop
it until it has no choice and then the
issue is whether President Trump and the
US political system is going to impose
those costs on Beijing to make it stop
now we certainly can do that China is
vulnerable on a number of different
fronts so for instance just that that
seven-year ban on ZTE that was imposed
in
people just was a death sentence for the
company president Trump gave it a
reprieve but we could put for instance
the largest Chinese banks out of
business because they've been laundering
money for North Korea we can cut them
off from their dollar accounts that
would shake not just the Chinese
financial system but the Chinese economy
and political system and you have a
Chinese economy now that senior people
in Beijing are privately saying is
growing at no more than one point seven
percent some people are saying that the
Chinese economy is contracting so you
know Beijing is not really in a position
to challenge the United States unless it
intimidates President Trump into caving
in now that's entirely possible but I
don't think that it will happen right
now for a number of reasons mr. Chen let
me just ask you we've just got about a
minute left in the show but are you
saying that the statistics the numbers
that China presents to the world about
its economy are they purposely wrong and
incorrect and exaggerated yeah I think
that they probably are we saw that order
from the National Bureau of Statistics
in Beijing to the guangdong authorities
not to publish their purchasing managers
index when Beijing tries to essentially
control economic data is a really bad
sign and as I mentioned Chinese figures
at Redmond University are saying look
this economy is not growing any more
than 1/7 so I think when they say that
they're growing at 65
well you can't account for that other
than purposeful Distortion
all right yeah interesting and valuable
insights tonight from Gordon Schoen
joining us tonight from Florida mr.
Chiang we appreciate it thank you